- YouTube. What's good.
Today, I wanna talk
about content strategy.
This is something I've been
blasting on for 15 years
and it's something that's
evolved quite a bit.
So I wanted to make this
video, to break it down.
The evolution, the ebb and flow,
how things have changed,
updated, contextualize it
and bring you the most value,
as I download my thoughts
on content strategy.
(whooshing)
The number one thing
you should do more than anything,
is use this interview as the case study
to become a better micro storyteller,
to under-, to awareness against this,
let me explain.
You'd probably don't
have a Tumblr account.
- [Joe] No, no. Here's the thing
- Oh and by the way, I don't
do it super-well either,
even though I was an investor,
but let's stick here,
because I wanna be detailed.
You should start one.
You should have, "I Love
Marketing" Tumblr account.
Because there's plenty
of 14 to 21 year old,
you know, hipsters that love,
that love, Tumblr, right?
That have never heard of
you, me, or anybody else,
'cause they're in the streets.
They're cool.
But they wanna be entrepreneurs.
You take one moment from here,
where you're holding up the wallet,
or where I'm being silly
and you make it an animated GIF.
You know what an animated GIF is, right?
- [Joe] Yeah.
- The looping over.
You put an animated GIF on Tumblr,
with one of the quotes from you or me,
from this interview.
And then that quote links back
to the iTunes download of this.
You have nobody on your Tumblr account,
just like anybody would when they start.
- [Joe] Right.
- But you take this interview
and you link your Tumblr.
You blast out an email and
say we're now on Tumblr,
and you 10, 11, 50-
It's un-
You know how it works, you start at zero
and you build, you should do that.
You should make an infographic
that's female centric,
things that you believe
the female psychology would
have gotten out of this,
and make an infographic and
start your Pinterest board
of infographics from your interviews.
You get one influential
Pinterest person to re-pin it
and you could have 10, 15, 100,000 people
get new awareness about your show.
And Pinterest is a dream.
It clicks out to wherever you want.
So your infographic
that you made from this,
seven fun things Gary said,
you know what infographics look like?
- [Man] Yeah.
- And that links out to
the podcast download.
I mean, this is the future man,
micro-content as a gateway drug,
to awareness to your bigger thing.
So put out micro pieces of content.
I'm a big believer.
And look, I think that
I'm hitting a golden era
in my content production: live streaming,
my Snapchat stories game is up,
my Instagram game is up, my
Twitter's still on point,
my Facebook fan page content is up,
LinkedIn is stronger than it was before.
Pinterest, we're still lagging.
We need to really get our
Pinterest game up. Right?
- [Man] It'll happen for
"Wine Library" I think.
- I know, we're talking about
me now, not "Wine Library."
You know, Pinterest needs
to get up a little bit,
but you need to put out micro-contents.
The reason I wrote "Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook"
is to get you to put out different
little pieces of content,
that still thematically ladder back up
to what you're doing on your website,
that are contextual for the platform.
Big Ed, don't get lazy on me.
You're Big Ed, go out there
and put out content across the board.
And don't just make it,
remember the jabs need to be jabs.
Don't just make the
content where you're like,
my biggest idea ever is: dot, dot, dot,
go to my website.
Your website will get
traffic as a byproduct.
And you were able to throw
(fist slaps)
right hooks, in those social platforms.
But put out jabs of value to the audience,
where they actually spend their time.
Big Ed, they love you
and they wanna go to your website
but they'd rather, more
than being on your website,
be in all these other places.
And it's up to you to be there
and use that as a gateway
drug, to get them back.
Well, look, I mean, you
should be putting out content,
on a very regular basis.
You should start a pillar show,
whether it's I mean, vlogging,
I think is very fascinating.
You know, you should be
doing Instagram stories
and Snapchat stories at scale.
You should be putting out
seven to 25 pieces of content,
on both those platforms a day.
- [Man] A day?
- And let me explain how.
Don't go fancy, document versus create.
When you make-
You like that, right?
It's a big, it's a big shift.
When I say seven to 25, you say: "My God,
how do I produce seven
to 25 meaningful things
that will have me
respected", versus document.
- [Man] See, that's always the thing,
is like, meaningful, that
will get you respected.
I feel like anybody can
put out shit, you know,
I don't want to put out shit.
- But shit is subjective, my man.
And I got good news for you,
you're fully in control.
- Yeah, yeah.
- People are always
like, Gary, you put up-
Like, I'm in control.
You know how many things I say no.
They send me quotes to
put on an Instagram. Nope.
I'm in control.
Who makes the final call
on like productions?
The producer, the director?
I don't know whoever,
who's the final person?
- [Man] Producer.
- Great. You're the producer, my man.
- Yes.
- Right? I don't know.
You take a selfie, with a nice skyline
and yeah, but you gotta put out stuff
and you gotta fabricate it.
Like, I still can't
believe how many people
that live in New York,
don't use New York people.
If I were you and I had an hour right now,
let's go in the fucking park right now,
like, I dunno, like go back
to your basketball roots,
stand outside the garden right there
and be like: "What do you think about
the Knicks upcoming season?".
Yeah, interviewing four people,
one person gets into a
thoughtful conversation;
he was the former ball-boy
in 1957. It's a nice story.
And boom, you see where I'm going.
Document over create.
How many of you heard that from me?
Document over create, great.
So, that took me a long time to get to.
Maybe like, seven years.
But it was the thing
(fingers snap)
that really unlocked
it for a lotta people.
Just for a lot of you,
my point on creating content,
is instead of trying to
think of what you make,
just document everything you're doing.
If you add-, do you know
that two or three of you,
if you just documented the
journey of figuring this out,
that people would watch your
video on YouTube every day,
of you trying to figure
out the school system.
And that in itself is what
would build your business.
It's the story.
It's the, it's the journey
of an entrepreneur.
The legacy that I'm creating
with DailyVee, fuck, you know how cool
that's going to be when there's
10 years worth of my every day.
Especially if I pull off very big things
I would love- you know how fun
it would be to watch the three years
before Drake became
famous, everything he did.
- So what was the
inspiration to start this
and to really-, it must be a lot of work
- You know, it's a lot more,
it's actually not a lot of work.
It's actually been an
incredibly smart strategy
to be honest, you know, I live my life.
Somebody documents it, they post produce.
I am not egotistical or too romantic,
and so I don't really get
involved in post-production.
I mean, literally I don't even know.
I mean, it doesn't take a lot work at all.
Which is scary compared
to the impact it has,
it creates a consistent show, which works.
It also feeds all my written audio
and other micro video content.
I mean, the fact that
I can put out a clip,
on Instagram a couple of days ago
that gets a million organic views,
and have that branding in that, you know,
20 to 35 demo that I'm
so desperate to have.
And the fact that that was
just one moment of me being
at Wine Library on a Saturday,
giving a 13 year old kid
some advice, that we
post edited and chopped
up in post-production on
my media team internally;
that's incredible.
Like I'm, I think I figured
it out, macro content
at scale, which then creates
micro content at scale;
all of which doesn't do anything
to me other than forced me
to actually live my life.
I'm not doing anything today
for Daily, I'm living life.
And so it's a very interesting
thing that I'm doing
because I'm confusing a lot of people.
I've created an incredible perception,
that I spent all my time
on my personal brand,
in a world where I spend
none of my time on my personal brand.
- [Man] You talked a little bit about
quality being subjective,
in a lot of ways that that
comes to play with this idea.
I, wanna push back a little bit on that.
- Please.
- Yeah, because I mean, at least
from my own experience,
it's been producing one
high quality video every single week.
And that's like,
eventually what it became.
In the beginning: it was podcasting,
I'm doing eight teasers
for every single podcast,
I'm putting them on social,
I'm sharing them with the
people that were on my show.
And it became so much work when I was
seeing a massive return on
these short edited videos
that I was making eight to
10 minute videos on YouTube.
And then it became for me
how can I make one
amazing video every week,
versus five decent videos?
- That's what worked for you.
- Yeah.
- And for Steven Spielberg it's one movie,
you know, a year.
Yours is doing way too
much volume for him, right?
And for me, it's not even
close to enough volume,
because I think there's 47
meaningful pieces of content
potentially in this 40
minutes we spent together.
I think that's right.
I think that goes back to
self-awareness and back
to the theme that's I think
evolving here, which is
this is very contextual, you know?
I think that's right for you.
And by the way, I think the debate
for you is, if you know, how
much micro content does come
out of this 40 minutes.
- It used to be a lot more.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And I mean, it was just for me-
- Here's the question.
And if you hire somebody
for $40,000 a year
who's great at it, in
post-production contextual to social,
will it be much more and will that lead
to much more awareness to the top
of the macro piece of content
that you're passionate about?
- [Man] Yeah.
- And then it becomes
one of your ambitions.
- [Man] Exactly.
- Do you wanna make that investment?
So I really don't think
there's a right or wrong.
I think that what I'm
passionate about is, oh my God
there's a permission for an
enormous amount of content.
And for you, this is been
the way it played out,
But for some people, a
single piece of micro content
on Instagram became the piece
that brought them awareness
to their long form YouTube video-
My number one thesis is producing content
at scale right now, it
is such an opportunity.
I couldn't, you know,
I'm going to beat this horse
until, not only is it dead,
but it's buried and I throw a bomb on it.
You know?
(Audience Laughs)
This is, this is, for everybody in here
who's nowhere close or not
at where they want to be.
It is absolutely the most
cost effective way to
start the process to whatever you want;
it is about producing content,
producing content at scale,
for as many platforms as possible.
So many people in this
room could have all the
things that they wanted
to happen on YouTube
and on Instagram for the
last three and a half years
and has not happened, actually happen
if they get serious about Tik
Tok for the next six months.
What is amazing about the
volume model, is the notion
of marketing for the
sake of better marketing.
So what happens after
you post those 78 is you
start getting quant and qual feedback.
And what you do with
that feedback is you make
the next decision, which is,
are you going to write more
about that?
Or, has there been such a huge
reaction to people's response
on what 5G actually means
to their day to day,
not just faster and better
battery, but how our entire world
changes when you create
that speed of information;
how that actually makes
the autonomous cars real,
how that actually allows
a doctor in Peru to
perform a surgery on somebody in New York,
how that actually,
actually, actually does.
When you see the response,
now all of a sudden
you say: "You know what
that little three sentences we
said about did you know when
5G is in your life, this happens?".
That's such a big response.
Why don't we now have
our graphic designer make
an infographic real quick around
five things you don't know
about 5G, and let's post
that at 3:37 PM today.
And then when that goes
well then you decide why
don't make a quick little
video on our iPhone talking
to Lars in RND.
He knows a lot about this shit.
Let's go over to him.
Lars says, and then you just post it.
Not with what's quality, with
green screen and lighting,
I mean I was powdered before
I came out here right now.
(Audience Laughs)
That to me is not the variable
of success of this talk.
(Audience Laughs)
That was not going to be the
variable that made this go well
or not.
(Audience Laughs)
It was what I was going to say.
- YouTube watcher what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you:
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.